hello everyone i'm jindal wong i'm very
glad to introduce our work cursed itself
flat agent this is a joint work with
adam adam and evening in this work we
explore the auction design for agents
who suffer the winner's course
let's first consider an auction game
called the wallet game in this game
alice and bob put all their money into a
wallet
alice has x and bob has wine
they all know the amount of their own
pocket money but not the others but they
all know that x and y are independently
uniformly distributed between 0 and 100
northward is auctioned back to them
using a second price auction
suppose you're bought and you know you
have thirty dollar put it into the
wallet hold a bit
intuitively as the
as the expectation of address money is
fifty dollar so this is what it is was
eighty dollar to bob the expectation and
as it is a second prize option just for
the bidding is optimal so it's very
natural for bob to be 80.
but here is a problem of using this
strategy
bob's strategy is actually beating his
own money white plus 50 dollar
suppose alice
adopts the same reason as bob should
also bid her own money x plus 50. so in
this case bob only wins when his own
amount of money is greater than alice
so conditional case of bob wings alice
money is no more than 30 and the
expected value of the wallet that bob
can win is only 45
instead of 80 as would bob expects on
the other hand as evidence strategy is
also beating
x plus 50 so the expected payment of bob
when he raised which is 65
so it turns out that bob loses 20
expectation if he wins
this phenomena is called the winner's
curse it happens in interdependent
valuation auction where the item's value
is jointly determined by each agent's
private signal and the winner often
behaviorally overestimates the value of
the item and pays more than
it was
the wheel curve has been consistently
observed in many real-world
interdependent options such as
auctioning the lawyer training rights or
book publication rights or baseball
players there are more examples of it in
the book by
keggle and levine
sometimes the results of the winter
skirts are serious
that may lead to bankruptcy of companies
as they may overpay what they get from
auction items making unable to provide
service public
evidence also shows that when the
company learned that it could not have
accurate information about
the item and may overheat that supposing
the win occurs the company is less
likely to join future options
an example is companies that do not
allocate in the neighborhood of the oil
field for auction
also aston and robin have also
established classic series to model the
behavioral feeders that may serve
awareness curse
so in this work we study the problem of
designing good matrices to remove the
negative effects of the winner's purse
in particular we do not want the winner
to lose money we do not want them to get
negative utility and background or are
not willing to participate future
options
and we provide a positive answer to this
question we can design such mechanisms
but as a consequence the auctioneer may
have to compensate for bidders
conversation may not be good for
auctioneer so we further study in which
cases the auctioneer can can achieve
good social welfare and revenue
in this talk we will focus on the social
weather part where our paper also
presents the results about the revenue
part
in the following we will introduce our
auction setting first then the
behavioral model we use for the crust
agent and finally the mechanism design
problem
for the auction setting we consider a
single item symmetric object setting
there is a set of an agent which was a
preference signal as i that's the amount
of money each player has in the world
game
and there's a public non-symmetric
distribution about signals
and the variation of the item is jointly
determined by all the signals for
example it could be
the sound of your own signal plus a
rescue with some other signal we also
assume that this valuation function is
symmetric for origin
and it increases in all signals
we also focus on direct auction
mechanisms each in
these mechanisms each hli submits a bit
b i
to represent its signal as i and the
mechanism consists of an allocation rule
denoted by x and a parallel
denoted by p i
consequently the utility of an ngi is
given by the validation gates from the
item miners is payment
we also use sigma to denote the bd
strategy which specify the probability
density of reporting a certain bit given
a certain signal to simplify the
notation inside
when the context is clear we will drop
the notation as minus i so here are two
examples so when you find something is
missing just remember it is for some
different
signals of all other agents
now we are going to introduce our
behavior model for curse agent
let's recall the word again bob thinks
that the fellow of the item is always 80
giving his signal 30.
he ignores that when the others beats
this that him so that he wins the other
signal is also disliking leading to a
lower federation of the wallet than he
expects but given 80 as the true values
of the agent then bob to be truthfully
and rationally
in other words bob can do equilibrium
listening correctly well the issue is
when he considers his utility he
neglects the contingency between other
agents actions and their signals
this is a philosophy of esther and
robin's model to capture the winner's
curse
more formally
here is the expected utility of agent i
given the bitter given bits of all
bidders
and the agent's eyes own private scale
under certain bidding strategy
a fully irrational agent will compute
this joint distribution of other speeds
and signals
using basin rule correctly
while fully cursed agent will compute
this joint distribution of other signals
and bits as independent conditional is
own signals
so she ignores the contingency between
these two sets of variables
moreover there is a partial crystal
agent called key crystal agent she
estimates this joint probability as a
linear combination of both the correct
estimation
and the current estimation with a mixing
coefficient here
so we can write out the expected utility
based on this wrongly perceived joint
probability denoted by
eohi and in the model cursed agents play
the
equilibrium strategy with based on the
strongly perceived expected utility
functioning eog
this model has an elegant observation
the key cursor expected utility can be
equivalently written
right and out by this correct joint
probability of other signals and big but
with a wrongly perceived valuation
function vip here
this wrongly perceived valuation
function is also a linear combination of
the correct variation and the
expectation given the patient's own
signal as i
we call this federation the cursed
evaluation for h9
so given this the behavior of an cursed
agent is actually equivalent to the
behavior of a fully rational agent but
with a cursed validation function
this is exactly what bob does in the
world thing he rarely perceives the
valuation function of lighting
but a valuation of knight but busy
rationally
based on this wrongly perceived value
in the one thing
astonishing robin did human subjects
experiments and showed that a key around
0.6 depicts the bidding behavior best
now we're going to discuss our mechanism
design problem
we want the mechanism to be exposed
instead of compatible for pressure agent
that means when the pressure agent
carries out the exposed equilibrium
resin transfer reporting is the
equilibrium strategy we call it cursed
exposed ic property and we use the
length c
to denote the word curse
second we want the mechanism to be
exposed in the future rational focus
agent that also means that when they
carry out the exposed equilibrium
analysis the equilibrium gives them
non-negative utility based on their own
calculation of the utility
these two properties does not guarantee
the agent one data in true negative
utility as these two properties are
based on the first reasoning so we in
particular when the winners does not
lose money in any circumstance and want
to remove these negative effects of the
venus curse
this is the true exposed ir
individual property referring to the
true valuation of the agents
now let's focus on the first two
properties the crystal exposed ic and ir
properties we can write them out
following the traditional definitions
but with a cursed utility instead of the
correct utility function
by the equivalence result we just
mentioned these two properties are the
same to their current parts for the
rational agent but with a cursed
variation function by key
so for this reason we can immediately
obtain the space of all direct
cursed exposed ic ir magnificence using
the missing dilemma
first the allocation rule can be an
effective monotone temperature rule and
second the payment rule
follows the misses payment identity
given the allocation rule
this gives the whole space of currency
exposed ic and ir mechanisms
now we want to move forward to add the
winner to add the condition to make when
it does not lose money so which is a
true exposed ir condition
for everything it turns out that adding
this constraint makes a mixing of the
cursed federation and the true
foundation in the whole system and is
super challenging to analyses
therefore in order to give some
analysable insights for option design
with close agent return to the
deterministic option setting
in deterministic mechanisms the monitor
allocation rule becomes the threshold
allocation rule for example for the
two-player case the allocation rule for
agent 1 is to first draw a threshold
function based on the signal of agent 2
as this red controls
and if h1 signal is greater than the
threshold given signal 2 then
you just allocate the item to agent 1
and we call this threshold for agent 1
the critical bid for her
then the payment
for the agent is just the cursed
validation of the item at its critical
bid
plus the initial payment at the sales
signal that agent now that
in these equations we have
dropped the subject s minus i for the
variation function and payment function
then we can add back the winners
know those constraints
the exposed ir cos two exposed ion
constraints now let's see what the new
mechanism looks like if agent i lose it
gets zero and plays
pi0 which is smaller cell so it already
satisfy the true exposed ir condition
and the engine wonders
on the other hand if h2i wins then it
will get vi
and paste vi here at the critical bit of
the agent plus pi0 so if this vi is
greater than this
crystal variation at the critical bit of
the agent
then we're good the winner still has
positive utility
however if the true validation is at
this point which is smaller than the
crystal validation
little bit
then we need to adjust this initial
payment to be smaller and zero in order
to compensate the bidder
so that it will not
have an active utility
so we have this inequality here
and
this inequality should not only code for
a certain asset but for all the signal
of the agent that
fall in this range
so as this valuation function vi is
increasing so in the worst case
what we need to accomplish it
is
the gap between the true validation and
the pressure valuation as a critical bit
of the agent
so which is this inequality
combine both cases together we now get a
relatively simple new constraint to make
the cursed exposed ic and our mechanism
also to be a true exposed io authority
no bidder will lose money even when they
are cursed
now we have derived our first result
about what a deterministic cruiser
exposed ic and our mechanism look like
where the winner also never loses money
compared to the classic case it just has
one more constraint on the initial
payment of the agent
but now we also know that this
constraint means that if the allocation
rule is not properly chosen the ceiling
may
the cell may need to compensate the
bidders and the compensation is made
through the initial payment turn so
which means that even the b losses we
still need to compensate it
so a natural question is to ask how bad
the composition can be that can we do a
good balance of compensate between
compensation and other aspects of the
mechanism
now let's see the composition term if
you do not allocate then you introduce
no curse and you can just set initiative
still by which if you allocate then you
may get this connected leading to our
conversation so this shows a natural
tension natural tension between the
social welfare and the conversation
for example if you want to achieve full
efficiency then you need to always
allocate the
allocate the item to the bidder with the
highest signal so the critical bit of an
engine is always the highest signal
among others
using this feature we can easily
construct a natural variation function
like this
and the distribution of the signals like
this such that the composition increases
super linearly asymptotically
with respect to the number of agents and
the sulfur welfare actually only
increases linearly so which results into
a revenue loss increases super linearly
with respect to the number of regions so
that's really not a good thing for the
auctioneer
so we can see the problem of social
website maximization under the budget
concern of the auctioneer in particular
we want to achieve the exposed budget
balance which means that the auctioneer
never lose money it is said that for any
billing profile the sum of the payments
is always non-active
this again tends to be a very
challenging condition to incorporate
into the mechanism design problem
directly but we have a simple way to
address this
first consider seemingly stronger but
simpler property which is the no
positive transfer
a constraint which means that the cell
number never consists of the bidders now
in other words the payments all of the
payments are always non-negative for all
agents
well we show that if the valuation
function and the signal distribution
certify the personal monotonicity
then these two condition constraints are
equivalent
and this monotonically in general means
that if other signals accuracy decrease
and your own signals increases then you
are more likely to overestimate
the
value of the item and last supporting
the winner's curse so this is very
natural
property and the classic valuation
function just linear function and
concave sound function with independent
signals all the valuation function
the marks of the signals all satisfy
this monotonicity condition
so this property is the main building
block of our theory about the social
weapon maximization and one of the
technique challenges we have attacked
so the profitable purpose
the proof of the proposition use the
contradiction suppose there exists such
case that the compensation is needed
then we can interruptively lower
so it's written we show that if we
reduce one more agent signal to zero
then the agent also requests
conversation um by using the
monotonicity and the symmetry of the
signals
in the end we reach to a stage where
there's only one positive signal and all
other signals still but we still need to
complete all other agents in that case
if we sum up the payments they will find
that it will validate the exposed by the
balance condition
so
equipped with a previous proposition so
we could reduce the problem of designing
a exposed boundary balance mechanism
into designing no positive no positive
transformations
and to get such mechanisms we propose
the masking operations that is given any
stressful t if it induces a witness
curse
thus a conversation is needed that would
just
increase
the threshold into a point where there's
no curse and composition needed
so this figure shows just one type of
relationship between the true phonation
and the crystallization so there could
be others so this point may not exist
in that case we will raise the threshold
to the maximum possible
value of the signal so there's no
allocation will be made given fixing um
signal
profile of the other agents
we show that if we apply this masking
operation on the generalized security
allocation rule then we get the optimal
social welfare with the exposed budget
balance constraints
and the closely exposed i say air
constraints and the winner does not lose
money
and what he wins
this theory actually gave a very
interesting observation
if the validation function of the agent
is the max of all signals
then the winner is always cursed and the
optimal social weapon
where no winner moves money
and no compensation is made has to be
zero
so we are wondering is there a case that
the auctioneer can make good social
welfare with exposed budget balance
constraints
and the answer is yes if the valuation
function is a concave sound function and
the signals are independent we can
actually part of the four efficiency
when the number of meters is large
and the complete thumb functions are
just a concave concave function of the
sum of any increasing functions of
signals so it covers a wide range of
functions such as linear functions and
lp known functions
for all these functions were good to the
heart of the full efficiency result
consistency
coming back to our world again this
optimal social welfare optimal option is
to allocate the item to the bidder with
higher bid when the other bidders speed
also exceeds
50 dollars
and the high level integration is that
to achieve the balance of compensation
and social welfare we have to allocate
only when the majority of bidders are
the high-end bidders
so these are our results about social
welfare we also provide the revenue
optimal mechanism for pressure agents
and show that both the optimal revenue
and the optimal social weapon decreases
with when bidders are more cursed than
not
um
so overall we explored the mechanism
design problem for first agent and we
focus on the deterministic and symmetric
setting
it will be very interesting to
to extend outside into more general
settings such as randomized magnesium
and asymmetric
settings
another interesting problem is that what
happens if agents have heterogeneous
parameter key and what if the auctioneer
cannot know the exact key and can we
design credit rating mechanisms
a more promising direction is to relax
the exposed ic constraint
to
the interim ic constraint
this is because exposure i say
constraint requires the allocation rule
to be monotone and you have to allocate
to agents with the highest signals
if you focus on
inter ring incentive compatible question
then the allocation rule is not to be
monitored and you will have a large
space to select the winner and you may
not need to compensate
for this direction or this direction
bridgeman adult provided a very
interesting revenue maximization work
when the valuation function is the
maximum of the signal regions
that's all about our talk and thanks for
your lesson